[Music]
in dick cheese news whether dick cheese
here both of you if you're uncircumcised
it's bound to happen but if you wash a
all the time in oh yeah
care to jump in is that cheese shaped
like a dick for dick cheese is that like
a thing you don't know what did cheese I
don't know if that is trying to say
you're the cleanest we can do right now
so you take you take after your white
side that might be a horn in the States
okay yeah I was too but my parents
refused to cut off its took off my penis
skin well they give you more length with
that yeah I mean this really considered
lame yes I mean for him it is what
depends all you mention actually the way
that it works is when you get harder to
hit shrinks
there's the skin part shrinks all right
so there's no inches there's no plus
there's no benefit no this is what it
looks like though nigma smegma smegma
I've heard it's Magnum so this is a mel
school freshman that's an actual like
that's the actual term for dick cheese
yeah this is the dick head right we used
to call kid smegma every single day and
then he killed himself that your phone
fell off the cliff like your joke all
the big kid like in between over the
years things build up and when you pull
this back and finally release it yeah
cover it in a layer huh
what are you supposed to pull about
supposed to needs I don't know the age
like it's not like having a period you
just discover it when you're playing
with your penis once you start [ __ ]
it gets pulled back it doesn't it hurts
does it everything hurts oh yeah make it
sound like it's like pots no but it
feels like a [ __ ] feels like that
let's go to convenient though probably
things are not topics like this right
like it's literally like like this like
yeah yeah and then the skin is like that
and when you're when you're when you're
younger like it's the skin is tight if
you got a stretch like that we'll never
pull out that's what
okay my dude this was submitted by the
collector okay that's an interesting
name oh yeah a 24 year old man admits he
has never properly cleaned his penis no
I know where this is going this is
terrible this should be uncircumcised
what does he need to admit to this
because he was on the TV show in the UK
called the sex clinic and he went to
this doctor because for a while he had
been experiencing pain and a bad odour
and he didn't know to [ __ ] clean now
there are you stupid I'm assuming he's
not circumcised and does no one not to
pull it smells like you don't know like
always you don't know I'm smelling
something because that dick cheese it
buckets it's like glue like every every
uncircumcised guy knows about this
because you discover it and no one tells
you if you had a dad I told you or
whatever thank goodness but you could
jack off without pulling it back all the
way so then it's it's like glue so it's
stuck it hurts and then slowly by slowly
as you pull it back in like wait a
minute you're like wait a minute this
[ __ ] can go ow let's see how far this
[ __ ] like you'll feel like you're
[ __ ] it's gonna detach from your
dick if you pull it back enough how's
your experience with the same bar did
you when you were rolling it back were
you scared at the same time like like
like like you guys were at Scripps
College right now in a [ __ ] stage we
like young stools and after leg as I was
peeling my foreskin I said to myself
will the head detach from the
[ __ ] stem yeah it's kind of
like are you ever getting a contact
stuck in your eye uh-huh so you're it's
stuck back there right oh [ __ ] how far
does it go just keep pulling and it kind
of hurts how old are you when you did
this I think like right try to figure it
out for Isaac oh no you're not
probably between 6th and 8th grade when
you like first start playing with
yourself yeah and then you're like oh
let's pool our yard and then they start
pulling it back and then you're like
wait I think there's more to this yeah
every time you pull back your hurts yeah
so you're like wait there's more to this
but it's painful and then finally you're
like what the [ __ ] are you talking about
hole and then when you finally pull it
then you see the seam where it goes to
the [ __ ] that's the end of it [ __ ]
sighs I might have circumcised the doc
got me right when I was baby like he got
me but he didn't get it all the way yeah
so it's like a half job but they took
that teach you the clean a dick my mom
did oh yeah my dad was nowhere to be
found after 6:00 when I was 6
ok baby my mom had to teach me how to
clean my genitals I still have to tell
them like make sure you pull it on baby
after you heard their stuff there's way
more usually less to pull back you don't
have to cuz it doesn't hurt that's the
what that's the reason why you think
there's a little bit hurt because
there's so much crusty [ __ ] but it's
like you said what the cookie but the
crusty builds as a child and sucks for
you because my mom would even tell me
now cuz tyke is not circumcised and
she's like oh like you have to like help
him like you like slowly like pull it
back to watch your child and then look
that's not hurtling no you have to do it
it's a what are you talking about the
baby that's so small to clean that [ __ ]
yes that's what my mom would say you do
it a little bit I mean because I just
don't know how to deal with what does he
go like this oh no he doesn't care
should we put a hot towel on this I mean
like it's not sensitive no you both
never even saw the end of your dick till
you'd [ __ ] eighth grade this is
[ __ ] man I swear this bullseye
you won't believe that's wow this is
nice the max and you don't know it goes
further cuz it hurts so much
yeah this guy here he didn't find out
until I was 24 so that means he's been
at burgesses he's 24 he's had sex at
least 40 oh please put a dick cheese
what did you say he has seen his dick
head
let me show you guys the video extra
skin itch so he's all these girls worst
sex story though yeah oh my god smell so
bad
look he's exactly we've all heard one of
those and now these girls don't ever
want to suck dick because they think
politics smells thank you okay so the
video clip of this guy names that are we
gonna see the dick cheese no it is
manageable I can't do it it's always a
good thing
[Music]
no no because it's obviously really
sensitive yeah - then get a flannel it
hurts hope I'm just you know it sounds
better with it what the English accent
way to say it sounds classy uh-huh okay
so a lot of people who they were just
like whoa you have to go on national
television and find out did you get
affordably what I don't know I mean who
knows he what if he did it he's also had
a lot of sti's oh really
collecting in all the doctors that he
saw I never told him I know right I
don't know so can somebody explain to me
why it's called dick cheese no stars it
really looks like cheese Mon your dick
yeah so smegma the buildup of dead skin
oil and moisture oh gods late too
I'm sorry man take a [ __ ] pocket oh
you know how like you know sometimes
you're under your fingernail you get
like that socket stuck in there so when
I first pulled up your toes you mean
who's not fingernail toenail the first
time I pulled it back I had like knit
like lint glue mm-hmm yeah
the first time I pulled it back that
[ __ ] was like a [ __ ] scab or strike
it was a white [ __ ] piece of skin and
it looked like reptile skin cuz it was
crap and I was [ __ ] mortified and I
had to get a q-tip and scrub the [ __ ]
out of it and peel it
I soaked lasers it was hurting me like a
[ __ ] Oh No but after I felt so
refreshed like this is what a dick is
supposed to look like what did you find
out that like you weren't circumsized
within other people were when I saw my
friends at school saying Elementary like
I was like first grade or some [ __ ] like
we yeah like you're being and then
you're like wait a minute it's not what
my penis looks like yeah and then you're
like wait what mom dad yeah show me
penis and it's just awkward but yeah I'm
like I think like third grade I asked my
parents I was like can I get circumcised
and to like no why would you want to do
we just don't do that and I'm like okay
I want to be like my friends when we pee
together ask them to add reason it's the
most bogus way every two I want to look
at my friends when we peed again a dog
like it's like when I'm with my other
like friends like like that are
circumcised like we're peeing in the
same toilet and I'm like man I'm
different my Japanese friends like most
of us it's like hit or miss you know
Japanese Americans maybe they'll get his
circumcised the the kid straight from
Japan know and then like we're all
peeing and I'm like yeah I'm like these
guys maybe we just have different dicks
we'll see I never knew anyone who had it
like mine because mine was a half chop
so I never had anyone to relate to so I
wonder if you ever thought about what
that would be right a half I could
I got ya thanks feel like you have both
options because you kind of push the
skin forward he could be like everyone
else wait to pull the fact shapeshifter
dude dude Nikki hit the floor - mistake
are you circumcised or not not to brag I
miss being with my friends you know my
god hanging with your friends it's not
the same we pee together you pee in the
shower together you can still do it if
you go - no we'd be together
no wait Dom yeah Dom Kiko tell me this
story you beat me - that's the golden
shower actually disappear no in the
shower and one guy has to go to a
bathroom and and everyone can't wait to
all go to the bathroom together in the
same toilet no no I did that crossing
streams yeah like I can't wait like oh
you're gonna go pee I gotta pee - and
then like everyone sits there and
disappointment and everyone pees in the
same toilet
he was the awkward [ __ ] loser kid in
the corner awkward loser I was a team
with my friends now that is a loser
really this is how tight we were all
three of us we have four friends if
three friends want to go pee if I need
to pee I'm I'm coming to you yeah that's
cold
I pull my passed out anyways yeah I mean
I can't wait I would do it but in a
different toilet I'm in the same [ __ ]
exactly oh that makes sense
that is the purpose go to the bathroom
with your friends you don't go into the
scene John is your girl dude these are
on Soylent right back on top of each
other one toilet
there's okay I'm Sora's house yeah and
then what what do you mean different
John there's a one bathroom I'm talking
about being at school
oh well actually I could do that school
Ashley that's all anyone did at school
this whole thing where guys who are
hanging out at one house they all go to
the same baths in the same time is
[ __ ] me my friends are at my house
right we're watching TV together someone
here to go pee your poor mother we all
went to we all went to the toilet and
more weird to me then at school it's
loaded that up great I forgot when it's
thought I miss those days have you guys
heard of blood brothers yeah course
that's the same thing it's kind of like
same thing piss brothers yeah like all
each other's penises while peeing - oh
that was just
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]